[Music]
today we cancel a gentleman by the name
of james rose i'm sorry i suppose i
should refer to him as gentlemen rather
than man because he identifies as a they
as multiple people
on his website james says that he is a
genderfluid actor living in new york
city and also includes this note
james writes about gender liberation
eating disorders uh trauma sex their
feelings and their exes on instagram
where they intend to leave the world a
little better than they found it
because you know there's no better way
to improve the world than by talking
about your feelings on instagram but
james is not just a genderfluid actor an
instagram diarist he's also a
self-described gender educator now you
may have noticed that literally anyone
can describe themselves as an educator
these days which is no surprise because
literally anyone can describe themselves
as literally anything these days no
labels have any meaning
words are all empty in this utopia of
ours so shoot for the moon i mean
speaking of which i'm going to start
describing myself as an astronaut in
fact i'm a i'm a gender astronaut
what does that mean well it's up to me
to decide
your job is to listen and nod your head
respectfully as if you know what that
i'm even trying to say
that brings us back to james who in his
role as gender educator will often post
tick-tock videos lecturing cis women as
he calls them
about all of their many failures and
foibles most recently he posted a video
explaining to women that they're not
allowed to feel uncomfortable
when penises are flying around in front
of their faces in the locker room listen
to him a lot of cis women share this
sentiment and i do want to break it down
this may be uncomfortable to sit through
and to listen to and i think that's why
it's important that we do this feeling
like trans people are a threat to you in
a space like a bathroom or a locker room
is actually a version of internalized
misogyny which is not necessarily your
fault because it's impossible to divorce
our socialization from the prevalence of
patriarchy but it also does mean it's
our responsibility to unlearn it for the
safety of fellow women especially trans
women in my experience as a gender
educator the majority of cis women who
have experienced violence at the hands
of men or just patriarchy or living in
today's world see anything that codes to
them as remotely masculine male etc and
fear it which in many ways is a survival
tactic that makes sense the difference
is when we code trans people as the
wrong gender we're actually doing them
way more a disservice than we are
protecting ourselves because you're
ostracizing and further alienating trans
people the false media narrative and
trope around trans people is that we are
predators that are tricking people into
thinking that we're something that we're
not which is of course not true watch
the documentary disclosure on netflix if
you want more on that so being
uncomfortable with trans people in your
space is something that you were taught
and you can unlearn that it's important
to recognize that we can't tell
someone's gender by their presentation
by their genitals by the way that they
look all of that can be changed all of
that is arbitrary none of that is
central to your identity necessarily
you know
if the word mansplaining has any
application at all that would have that
would have to be it i think so let me
translate here's what our friend james
is saying to the ladies out there
he's saying shut up you stupid girls and
let him get naked in front of you
and people like this often get away with
saying the most hideous things and being
absolute tyrannical bullies and
predators because for one thing they're
in an in an approved victim group
but also because of this grating
irritating faux compassionate tone they
use now any semi-aware person can
recognize that this smug little bastard
is being condescending and patronizing
as hell
and that he's doing it in an effort to
emotionally black male women into
allowing men to sexually harass them
but the dumber non-aware people a large
demographic in this culture these days
unfortunately will hear this and they'll
say well he sounds like he's being nice
we should listen to whatever he says
the interesting thing
is that james's message which is often
the message of trans activist
is that your feelings as a woman are not
valid he all but comes out and says that
your feelings don't matter
you need to change your feelings
in fact he knows more about your
feelings than you do he's conducted a
therapeutic diagnosis of all the women
in the country all at once and he's
decided that your discomfort with
strange penis in the locker room is
internalized misogyny
did you get that
so if you as a woman do not want to see
him as a male get naked in front of you
you are a misogynist
you are now essentially the man in that
exchange not him and he is the victim of
your misogyny
this is coercion of the most twisted
kind all in an effort to compel women to
sit quietly while men expose themselves
if you feel like you are getting the
respect you deserve in life well i've
got a solution for you established
titles is your opportunity to earn the
title of lord or lady and gain the
respect you deserve all you need is a
one square foot plot of land in scotland
in your title pack you'll receive at
least one square foot of dedicated land
on a private estate and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land these title packs
are a fantastic gift and the best way to
surprise your loved ones from
girlfriends or boyfriends or even family
you could even get a couple pack for you
and your partner where you can get
adjoining plots of land
well with this certificate you could
officially change your name to lord or
lady and get it on your credit card your
plane ticket etc
establish titles is having a great
extended new year's sale so go to
establishtitles.com matt walsh to save
10 off today and remember to use the
discount code matt walsh or just click
the link below that's established titles
dot com matt walsh or just click the
link below louis ck was cancelled with
righteous fury by the mob when he
exposed himself in front of women except
that in his case he asked for permission
ahead of time
doesn't make it okay but he did
still it was argued that even with
consent there was implicit coercion
because of the power that he had over
the women in the interaction
well
what about men who who do not ask for
permission before exposing themselves
and who apply explicit coercion to shame
women into silence and acquiescence
by the standard already applied to many
high profile men in much in much more
ambiguous circumstances these guys are
our sex predators
now the simplified view of our cultural
ethos is that feelings are given first
priority feelings matter above all else
i've often said this myself as recently
as yesterday
and it's true but the statement needs
qualification because it's more accurate
to say that some people's feelings
matter above all else
if feelings in general were given pride
of place then james rose would be
roundly condemned by everybody
for recording videos lecturing women
about the illegitimacy of their feelings
he's allowed to do this because his
feelings as a member of the lgbt camp
are of utmost importance
primary importance
but the feelings of a woman especially a
white cisgender woman quote unquote
don't necessarily rank at all
and when her feelings are made to
contest with the feelings of the sacred
alphabet people
her feelings are then ascribed a
negative value
her feelings aren't just unimportant
they're bad they're shameful they are a
sin that must be punished a disease that
must be cured
see if the left put an overemphasis on
everybody's feelings
and they were obsessively concerned with
making sure that nobody ever felt sad or
uncomfortable that would still be bad
and dangerous in its own way but at
least we could call them
well-intentioned we could even say that
their problem isn't an overabundance of
compassion or a kind of misdirected
misappropriated compassion
either way
they would be good people they'd be nice
people a little bit too nice
just misguided
that's not the case though
on balance it turns out that they care
less about feelings than even i do
because there's only a very select group
of people whose feelings rank at all and
everybody else can go to hell they say
let's look at one more clip from james
as he now responds to some of the
comments taking issue with the video we
just played listen to this
so you've caught me at the time when i'm
not feeling diplomatic and i'm just
gonna yell this is a horrible comment
and i don't need to defend any of my
behavior aka walking down the street as
a freaking non-binary woman
feeling uncomfortable with trans people
walking down the street is just your
transphobia because as a fellow femme i
understand the danger and the terror and
the fear of walking around on the street
especially at night i live in new york
city don't even get me started and
because i'm aware of what it feels like
to be on the receiving end of that as a
femme and as a non-binary woman when i
see another potentially feminine
presenting person in front of me i will
say things like coming behind on your
left or just don't want to scare you
coming behind on your right something
that lets them know that i'm there so
they don't feel fear and i do this as a
courtesy on the off chance they
misgender me and think i'm a man that's
just camaraderie and looking out for
each other the fact that you feel like i
would be unsafe on the street is
literally just a coding for i don't
conceptualize you as a non-binary person
or as a woman i don't need that energy
on my page get out
so somehow we've gone from talking about
locker rooms to walking down the street
i'm not sure when that shift in the
conversation happened but even so first
of all note how he a male identifies as
a non-binary woman
now non-binary if it means anything at
all which it doesn't means that
someone is not a man or a woman so he a
male is also a woman but also neither a
man nor a woman but also a man
and not only does he hold this
incoherent jumble of self-identities in
his confused head but it also is your
responsibility as a woman to know that
just by looking at him as he passes by
in the street
now james and his generosity
he will give you permission as a woman
to be nervous when you're alone at night
and a man walks by
he will allow that
so you should say thank you to james for
that because he's going to let you have
that feeling
say thank you mr james or miss james or
whatever
but if the man walking by identifies as
a woman or if he identifies as a woman
who identifies as neither a man nor a
woman
but as a man then you must not feel
nervous
you must intuit his self-perception in
that moment you must absorb it into your
being in a split second and if you don't
then you're transphobe
this is the way the world works
according to this pompous overbearing
megalomaniacal ass
you must conform to his version of the
world
that's what you have to do
or you can simply tell this person and
every bullying narcissist like him to
piss off
and also you can tell him that he is
canceled that's what i would recommend
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated